[Music]
foreign
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month the year was 1982 when a gallon of
gas cost around 90 cents a 19 inch color
TV set you back 500 bucks and Disney's
futuristic Park Epcot first opened and
in the world of movies and TV Sylvester
Stallone continued a major movie
franchise while also kickstarting
another one a certain extraterrestrial
was trying to phone home and times were
moving fast at Ridgemont High plus
Michael J fox a talking car and a place
where everyone knows your name were all
introduced to prime time TV audiences
okay it's time to go backward a full
four decades yep it's been 40 years
here's your year in review 1982 Edition
thank you
for lunch all right who's next
oh
[Music]
because I didn't want to mess with
anybody else and the first movie we're
going to talk about today is perhaps
best known for tomorrow tomorrow it's
Annie it's Annie we're gonna talk about
Annie hitting theaters in May this
musical Stars Eileen Quinn as the
high-spirited young Orphan Annie who
goes from living in an orphanage run by
the evil Miss Hannigan played by Carol
Burnett to living with a rich eccentric
who is looking to improve his image but
Annie just wants to find her real
parents
it's nice to meet you
meet you we're bringing the old
him yet inconceivable don't mind him
Oliver this marks the first adaptation
of the 1977 Broadway musical and was
followed by a made-for-tv sequel in 1995
with a handful more adaptations of the
original play and the years that
followed Annie went on to earn two Oscar
nominations including one for best
original score but despite being the
10th highest grossing film of 1982 the
high production cost kept it from making
much money and the reception was mixed
critics say John Huston proves an odd
choice to direct myring Annie and a
sluggish stage-bound mess of an
adaptation but the kids are cute and the
songs are memorable
nobody else does this much for charity
Bob Hope would
it's true and from one single named
character to another although this one
is a bit different May of 1982 also
brought us Rocky III this sequel to
1979's Rocky 2 was the second film in
the franchise to be directed by
Sylvester Stallone who also returned to
Star as the one-time working-class boxer
Rocky who's now a rich and famous world
champion but after losing his title to
Mr T's Clubber Lang Rocky turns to an
old Foe for help in trying to reclaim
his past Glory
oh
Not only was this the feature film debut
for both Mr T and Hulk Hogan this was
also the Rocky movie that introduced us
to survivor's eye of the tiger a song
that became an oscar-nominated Smash Hit
and a huge part of popular culture for
decades and Rocky 3 was a knockout at
the box office as well becoming the
highest grossing installment in the
franchise at the time and the fourth
highest grossing film of 1982 with 270
million dollars critics say it's
noticeably subject to the law of
diminishing returns but Rocky 3 still
has enough brawny spectacle to stand in
the ring with the franchise's better
entries
[Music]
thank you
I'll be
right
here
Crash Landing in June of 1982 was the
worldwide phenomenon known as E.T the
Extraterrestrial a Steven Spielberg
directed film about a young boy who
discovers and befriends an alien one
that really needs to go home this sweet
tale features Henry Thomas who has gone
on to appear in a bunch of movies like
Gangs of New York and more recently
doctors sleep plus a young Drew
Barrymore who was seven when the film
was released and already established
herself as a star each he closed out the
Cannes Film Festival a couple weeks
prior to the U.S release in June and
went on to become the highest grossing
film of all time until Spielberg's own
Jurassic Park stomped it down to number
two in 1993.
remember that the things that you are
writing down the 99 certified fresh film
also won four of nine Oscar nominations
including the man John Williams winning
for what is just one of many iconic film
scores critics say playing as both an
exciting sci-fi adventure and a
remarkable portrait of childhood Steven
Spielberg's touching tale of a homesick
alien remains a piece of movie Magic for
young and old
[Music]
I don't know what the hell's in there
it's weird and pissed off whatever it is
bennings go get child this movie was the
thing when it came out on June 25th 1982
as in It's called The Thing directed by
John Carpenter the sci-fi horror flick
is about a group of American Research
scientists and remote Antarctica who
encounters some sort of alien thing that
can assume the shape of its victims Kurt
Russell stars in the film with a
Supporting Cast that includes Wilford
Brimley Keith David DK Carter and
Richard Dysart but unfortunately all
those familiar 80s faces were up against
a much more family-friendly alien at the
box office by the name of E.T leading to
disappointing results
YouTube
foreign
[Music]
was initially released to an abundance
of negative reviews but it eventually
found its audience through home video
and TV airings through the years it's
gained a cult following and was
ultimately reassessed as one of the best
sci-fi horror films ever critics say
Grimmer and more terrifying than the
1950s take John Carpenter's The Thing is
a tense sci-fi thriller Rife with
compelling tension and some remarkable
makeup effects
unless you're alive you can't play and
if you don't play
and looking to outpace the thing on June
25th back in 1982 was the Ridley Scott
sci-fi film Blade Runner taking place in
2019 a pretty far-off future at the time
I'd suppose here's in Ford stars as
Deckard a former Blade Runner forced
back into his old job to hunt down four
replicants who stole a ship in space and
headed to Earth the film is an
adaptation of a Philip K dick novel
leading to more of his work being made
into big Hollywood Blockbusters like
Total Recall and Minority Report
all those
moments will be lost
in time
like
[Music]
tears
in rain
time
to die
[Music]
facing stiff competition and with a
story that caused confusion among
viewers at first it took this certified
fresh film a little while to achieve a
cult classic status but it's now
considered one of the best sci-fi films
of all time a sequel Blade Runner 2049
came in 2017 with Denise directing and
Harrison Ford returning to Star
alongside newcomer Ryan Gosling critics
say misunderstood when it first hit
theaters the influence of Ridley Scott's
mysterious neo-noir Blade Runner has
deepened with time a visually remarkable
achingly human sci-fi masterpiece
Sky's been stoned since the third grade
yes yeah I'm registered in this class
what class this is U.S history see the
globe right there really hey
did I come in oh please I get so lonely
when I hear that third attendance or a
ring and all my kids are not here and
checking into homeroom on August 13th of
1982 was the coming of age dramedy Fast
Times at Ridgemont High this film about
the loves and lives of high school kids
in California star Sean Penn Judge
Reinhold Phoebe Cates and Jennifer Jason
Lee and includes very early appearances
from future stars like Nicholas Cage
Eric Stoltz Forest Whitaker and Anthony
Edwards this marked the feature film
debut for director Amy heckerling with a
screenplay written by Cameron Crowe and
based on his 1981 book about the time he
went undercover at a San Diego High
School Arnold What's Happening
um they talk to me sure man uh I really
hate Bronco burger man ever since they
started with the chicken nuggets
everything went downhill you may have to
fry all the greasy food and everything
you have to polish things and the
manager is an [__] for me
I was just wondering Arnold you want to
work at All-American Burger Fast Times
went on to gain iconic status through TV
airings and home video releases thanks
to a few Unforgettable scenes with Sean
Penn once describing the film as taking
on a life of its own critics say while
Fast Times at Ridgemont High features
Sean Penn's legendary performance the
film endures because it accurately
captures the small details of school
work and Teenage life
[Music]
yeah you'll be fine I won't be fine I'm
too nervous I've gone over this state in
my mind a hundred times they're only
four times when I didn't spill something
you'll be all right just uh don't order
anything to drink big things were
happening on the small screen in 1982 as
well including the premiere of the
sitcom Family Ties which ran on NBC for
seven seasons and wrapped just before
the 90s hit which makes sense because
this series focused on two former
hippies trying to raise a traditional
family in Suburban Ohio during the
Reagan Administration often clashing
with their young Republican son played
by Michael J fox speaking of fox he got
the role after Matthew Broderick turned
it down and went on to earn three
straight lead actor Emmy Awards at one
point during the show's run not to
mention he became a full-fledged
Hollywood star also thanks to the Back
to the Future Trilogy which was produced
and released during this series's run
Alex what time did you get in last night
oh I don't know mother what is time
really
Family Ties has lived on in syndication
since the fall of 1987 and if you ever
come across it keep an eye out for
Courtney Cox who played Michael J Fox's
girlfriend during the last two seasons
fun facts critics say Family Ties
subversion of the generation gap is
initially more strained than inspired
but the warmth shared between the Keaton
Clan makes for an inviting sitcom with
Michael J fox an immediate standout as
the conservative upstart Hey kid how
about a little music huh sorry the alpha
sucker took out the radio too you're
never gonna forgive me for that are you
Michael forgiveness implies an emotional
state that has no application in my case
however I doubt that I shall ever forget
it nearly a decade before he was running
on the beach wearing a swimsuit on
Baywatch David Hasselhoff was riding in
a talking car and wearing a leather
jacket on Knight Rider which premiered
on September 26 1982. the series ran for
Four Seasons on NBC and star are the
Hoff as a sleek and modern crime fighter
named Michael Knight his partner was an
artificially intelligent souped-up
Pontiac Trans Am called kit which stood
for Knight Industries 2000. kit was
voiced by William Daniels who was also
starring in the NBC drama Saint
elsewhere at the same time although his
name was never seen in the credits for
Knight Rider per his request after the
series wrapped in 1986 the story
continued with Hasselhoff coming back
for a couple made for TV movies Knight
Rider 2000 in 1991 and Knight Rider 2010
in 1994. I know it's a lot of numbers
oh
[Music]
yeah
good work kid thank you Michael it was
all quite Elementary another TV movie in
2008 served as a pilot for a new series
with a Ford Mustang Shelby and Val
Kilmer making up the character of kid
this time standing for Knight Industries
3000 obviously but it only lasted one
season critics say this car can do
anything except paper over how
tiresomely silly Knight Rider's concept
is no I'm the best party I was ever at
was in a locker room right wall standing
around on our underwears pouring
champagne on each other guys playing
guys into showers it was terrific
called shows after we'd won the division
championship
that's right that's why we were all in
Cleveland right and premiering just a
few days later on September 30th and
forever changing sitcoms and prime time
TV in the process was the show about the
place where everybody knows your name
cheers this series centered around Ted
Danson's Sam Malone character a former
Red Sox relief pitcher turned owner and
head bartender at cheers Andy was joined
by an ensemble cast throughout the years
that include Woody Harrelson Kelsey
Grammer Kirsty alley Shelly Long John
ratzenberger and George Wendt AKA Norm
after being nearly canceled during its
first season due to low ratings the
series went on to run for 275 episodes
across 11 seasons on NBC earning Emmy
nominations for outstanding comedy
series 11 straight times and winning
four
let me do it I'm a smoothie about
breaking bad news
Sam your apartment burned down you lost
him oh my god really no no no your
brother's in town he's on his way over
makes you feel better doesn't it
it's hard to track all the different
guest stars and celebrity appearances
over the years which include people like
Johnny Carson Alex Trebek Arsenio Hall
Emma Thompson Harry Connick Jr and John
Kerry but what many people won't forget
is the series finale in 1993 watched by
an estimated 93 million people or about
40 percent of the country's population
at the time no wonder everybody knows
their names critics say with an
instantly comfortable setting as
endearing as its characters cheers lays
out the template for a classic Ensemble
comedy with its entertaining first
season
[Music]
thank you
I could have killed them all
I could have killed you
've been telling you the law out here
it's me
don't push it
don't push it I'll give you a war you
won't believe much like the spring of
1982 the fall included a major Sylvester
Stallone franchise film but instead of
Rocky this time it was the start of
Rambo with First Blood this action film
was co-written by Stallone who stars as
a misunderstood Vietnam veteran named
John Rambo who finds himself at the
center of a massive Manhunt and has to
rely on his combat skills to survive the
film is based on the 1972 novel of the
same name by David Morrell which was a
hot item around the industry in the
1970s before finally getting made in
1982.
look at him out there
up there look at him
if you don't have this now they're gonna
kill you
is that what you want
it's over Johnny
it's over
it is over
nothing First Blood performed well at
the box office and went on to become the
first Hollywood Blockbuster to be
released in China in 1985 and from there
it became a full-blown franchise with
four sequels all co-written by and
starring Sly plus an animated series
comic books novels video games and even
a Bollywood remake critics say much
darker and more sensitive than the
sequels it spawned first blood is a
thrilling survival Adventure that takes
full advantage of Sylvester Stallone's
acting skills
thank you
[Music]
man I don't think God none of my fellas
see me riding around this car man you
really let this [__] go bad she don't
understand I don't care how it looks you
ain't got no class Jack classes or
something you buy look at you you got a
500 suit on you're still a low life yeah
but I look good clocking in on December
8th in 1982 was 48 Hours marking the
first ever film role for a rising SNL
star named Eddie Murphy he landed the
part after top choices like Richard
Pryor and Gregory Hines turned it down
and ended up turning in a Golden Globe
nominated performance Murphy plays a
wisecracking criminal who teams up with
a no-nonsense cop played by Nick Nolte
and together try and catch two cop
killers within the time frame of 48
Hours take game man and blow his brains
out he ain't gonna try it right cop
thank you
are you crazy man I was just bluffing
this film would spawn the sequel another
48 hours in 1990 has been considered one
of the first in the buddy cop genre one
that would eventually include franchises
like Lethal Weapon bad boys and rush
hour despite Studio Executives never
really being that happy with the script
or Murphy's performance during filming
the certified fresh 48 Hours ended up
being one of the best reviewed movies of
the year and the seventh highest
grossing critics say marking an
auspicious feature film debut for Eddie
Murphy 48 hours is a briskly paced
action comedy that succeeds largely due
to the outstanding chemistry between its
two leads oh the prophecy says You must
find the shark
the crystal shard
Crystal shard
to shave our world guildling you
must find the shark and nothing says the
holidays like giving kids a little bit
of a scare which is exactly what the
Dark Crystal did when it was released in
theaters on December 17 1982 directed by
Jim Henson and Frank Oz and featuring
only animatronic puppets this film
follows Jen who after being raised by a
noble race called the mystics is told
that he is the last survivor of his own
race the gelflings oh here Daniel
what's that it's a land Strider Stan
yetamod
how did you learn to call him the
bubbling's taught me
and now he sets out on a mission to find
a Shard of the Dark Crystal a powerful
gem that once brought balance to the
universe The Dark Crystal was marketed
as a family film but ended up being much
darker compared to what Henson and Oz
were known for AKA The Muppets but the
animatronic technology used was
groundbreaking for the time with most
creatures needing roughly four
puppeteers to achieve the full effect
Jim Henson personally made some edits
after a disastrous preview including
redubbing some characters voices and
while final reviews were mixed initially
the film went on to achieve cult status
and in 2019 a prequel series premiered
on Netflix critics say The Dark Crystal
narrative never quite lives up to the
movie's visual splendor but it remains
an admirably inventive and uniquely
intense entry in the Jim Henson Canon
awfully I wondered if you wouldn't mind
buying Pizza Gregory
okay your favorite client how are you
last time you got me a job it was a
tomato yeah
I swear to God
yeah
oh God I begged you to get some therapy
and finally also hitting theaters on
December 17th to help finish out 1982
was the hit comedy Tootsie directed by
Sydney Pollock this film stars Dustin
Hoffman as a talented actor struggling
to find a job so he takes on a new
identity as a woman and lands a part in
a soap opera joining hoppin was a
Supporting Cast that includes Jessica
Lang Bill Murray director Pollock and
Gina Davis in her film debut and
speaking of Lang she brought home the
Oscar for best supporting actress the
only win from the film's 10 nominations
which included one for Best Picture
like I wanted me
I cannot believe the night I have had
tonight I think I could imagine oh no
you can't I sort of look in his eyes I
was in big trouble if you don't come in
I'm in The Daily News the next morning
how did you ever let him in here what do
you mean how did I let him in here he
was singing
is he that good a singer the certified
fresh Tootsie also became the second
highest grossing film of the Year behind
E.T with over 177 million dollars at the
box office Tootsie doesn't squander its
high concept comedy premise with fine
dialogue and sympathetic treatment of
the characters well that's it what a fun
trip through the year 1982. gotta love
the 80s the next step is checking some
of these out just remember these five
words Rocky Rambo Annie Tootsie and
cheers see you next time